foreign
[Music]
applesauce Cup who eats half an
applesauce cup and apple gave its whole
life for you [__] hey baby we are
Sonic Boom happening somewhere outside
indicating that a train was moving with
some urgency yeah the only indication of
him super speeding into the room is the
curtains being gently blown aside there
was this British guy a buzz cut french
guy big black guy with a goatee and a
skinny white kid I'll admit I'm curious
about the punch line to this joke setup
but there's no way it's going to be at
all appropriate so I'm gonna have to
send it and I fell for you right then
and there to tell this story right
before killing her is sociopathically
cruel which would be fine if it was
homelander but the show will continue to
try to draw empathy for a train even
after he needlessly needles someone he
supposedly loves right before he
literally needles someone he supposedly
loves heroin overdose did he run here
from Cuba he ran over water and you
didn't show it to us we want to see it
like Dash or sonic or Jesus
then a Sprinkle of salt and pepper then
I bake this recipe sounds simple but it
also sounds [__] delicious and
ultimately this food will end up tossed
on the ground Justice for La pule
tries to get us to buy into Stockholm
syndrome as a valid meat cute failing
Christ to the cross with your nipples
now powerfest caves for Christ
believe Expo reminding me of my rejected
script for Jason Bourne again still a
bit of a sore spot mom I like the idea
that these two were surprised by running
into each other at this event rather
than you know maybe sending a text that
you'd arrived and decided to go straight
to your hotel because the food was
better even though I haven't seen you in
like three months but sure yeah do that
not like I care if you I'm sorry what
was they saying again Jesus said hey bro
he did not people who have faith those
are my peeps y'all that's what Jesus
said thinking Jesus would want anything
to do with peeps he'd be like oh so I
literally came back from the dead and
you celebrated by eating tar flavored
marshmallow Birds thanks guys every
entrance on the holy hell this statement
prepare me for something more than one
handgun which is fine but your partners
might need to actually know a bit more
detail about what they're going up
against security is tighter than a koi
boys are we all get where he's going
with this off-color joke but what Billy
doesn't realize is it his delivery of
this line asserts his own first-hand
knowledge of choir boys as opposed to
the churches I I don't know how to
Blackmail anybody
you've done a murder comparatively
speaking this will be a piece of cake
comparatively speaking these are two
very different skill sets for example
I'm excellent TV sins but have never
satisfied a woman's thirst for knowledge
about the Roman Empire yeah that's it Dr
Julian Barrow
an esteemed French neurosurgeon Susan
Lopez from Evanston
and her daughter Maya show thinks that
professions in motherhood are the things
that make some human lives more valuable
than others and I'm just sitting here as
a non-mom who writes jokes about TV
shows for a living thinking okay so I'm
a bad example but I promise you don't
have to be a parent or a neurosurgeon to
have value
when did that happen what are you
talking about it's always been there
when did what happen and why does it
sound like you're discussing the
placement of a couch and not the
reprehensible comic book you've randomly
walked past using pretty big math to be
a dick because you're afraid of what
might happen if a stranger you don't
give a [__] about happens to order the
hot dog platter the clams casino or just
say screw it and Go a la carte yes I
know that this is the point the show is
making but it's not just acceptable to
do the math you need to show your work
um discount DJ cool covers it's private
but
no one else sees this and it's not wrong
having a little church opinion you know
suit the bishop to the nun writers have
Mother's Milk set this one up because
they thought the butcher improv's Comedy
Hour would work better as a Duo
let's do it you know for a team trying
to work together they sure do pull the
I'm not gonna tell you so the audience
can stay in suspense about something you
could probably know cliche card quite a
bit not labeling your drink station I
mean I probably guessed lemonade for
this one and this one might be iced tea
maybe but that still doesn't tell me if
it's sweetened or undrinkable just took
a lovely little stroll around St John's
and you'll never guess well I am the
cross was it a cleaning company because
no judgment but I've never arrived
unannounced to someone's home that looks
this spotless there's not even a single
fingerprint in sight I told you well
I'll tell you who didn't tell me writing
a scene so you can do an info dump but
then being reluctant is to actually dump
the info you like some tea
catering to the English I used your last
name you said beloved wife she buried an
empty coffin this is what caused him to
abandon his Partners when they were
right in the middle of blackmailing a
public figure Billy [__] maybe
melodramatic but this seems less about
that and more about his character not
having anything to do while Huey is
getting baptized it has been eight years
since she's been missing five days since
you laughed at me three days since the
living room but it'll still be two days
till I say I'm sorry
sudden Billy Zane is sudden Man Billy
Zane it was the bomb in the Phantom
[Music]
the convenience of this teddy bear
camera is only slightly more sinnable
than the discomfort I will have around
teddy bears from now on also if a train
knew this camera was here why did he
wait until now to view the footage
instead of stopping here as he's been
running back and forth between New York
and Havana a train Grieves by watching a
Cheesy movie pop claw starred in and
then some covert sex tape Shenanigans as
opposed to say not taunting her with the
story of how you met her before you
murder her
did you hear that static sound I hope so
because it's the only explanation we
will get as to why this hidden camera
has a cut to the exact relevant moment
for expedited plot progression setting
and I would very much like to welcome
homelander our special guest maybe I'm
underselling ezekiel's celebrity but if
homelander was going to be a special
guest here how is that not in the
marketing material using wooden stairs
in your baptismal not paying attention
to stomach circumference when doing full
immersion baptism this man's belly
button is still Unholy thank you
see your friend Huey immediately starts
to Blackmail Ezekiel after homelander
walks out of the door and somehow he's
not superheard lasered and or
disappeared your dick was so perfect and
long and
stretchy and you you played my butt like
jazz this sounds like Huey has never
been intimate with himself let alone
another human and it works who the hell
are you more importantly where the hell
did everyone else go no managers
bodyguards acolytes how does someone
this in demand and popular at this event
end up alone in an open tent for this
long you're like the rain man of people
over not a compliment or even funny
[Music]
clear from this first hit and later
kicking it over that this headstone
wasn't even attached to the bass Stone
and I know that's not how headstones
work because if it was my rural Michigan
high school friends would have gone
grave tipping on the weekends and left
the cows alone
it's not a hate crime no but it is a
crime crime
[Applause]
did homelander have this scripture
memorized for this moment he strikes me
more as a quoting from two Corinthians
type no this light is very close to the
wall almost too close I don't know why I
said it that way there's nothing devious
about this lamp or is there I'm not sure
who the first person was to film mirrors
that reflected someone else in the
conversation but I am sure that it's
been done enough that there isn't much
left to be gained by making me wonder
why this mirrors here in the first place
tell me what happened
mistaking compassion for compassion
so just talk to me just tell me what
this scene has some great writing and
great performances very quickly we're
able to learn so much about this
relationship as well as the toll maves
work has taken on her life it's a fish
ineffective and worth the sent off wait
a second didn't Butcher say I'll meet
you at the hospital in half an hour what
happened did the sun fall out of the sky
violence only our concerned mate despite
what I know I still hear soup on soup
violence and that is all I can think of
now this isn't about you isn't it moms I
mean I I kept your secret
screen by Selling Houses hard times can
be fall any industry so I'm not saying
it was all sunshine and rainbows but
that doesn't make it any less strange
for Starlight to be going along with the
I am but a lowly peasant realtor bit
that her mom is trying to sell us right
now
doesn't commit to making this butcher's
name in the long term are we the same
you and I like eggs hard outside soft
key inside or pineapples perhaps
comparing yourself to two things that
should never be a pizza topping the Deep
finds himself in hot water the news
should be less concerned with making
puns also I will of course in the
blatant news position but I'll also send
that the Deep changes the channel to the
believe Expo so that it can directly
reference him in a bit and that it is
apparently being broadcast live all day
quick name a fundamentalist Christian
Festival that's broadcast live on a
normal TV channel all day long and no
the Republican convention during
election years doesn't count when the
Bible was written life expectancy was 30
years old Methuselah has entered the
chat it also says that it's a sin to eat
shrimp it does dang it do you know how
many times people have eaten shrimp on a
TV show and I've stood by and said
nothing I'm guessing about 31. I'm just
as scared and confused as the rest of
you me responding to my friends when I
convinced them all to watch existence
somehow makes it into the episode baby
jack-jacking making opening fire your
first line of defense in a baby
superhero Factory
for aiming purposes butcher still
remembers to support the baby's head and
neck I gotta give credit where credit is
due but also where's the trigger on this
gun gratuitously milking the ratings
black noir is being pretty bad at
sneaking for a soup his power seems to
be mostly being good at sneaking and if
you think that he revealed himself as a
ruse trap Frenchie when he runs in the
other direction then ask yourself why
that would be better than normal
sneaking now since I can feel your
excitement growing the comment section
will self-destruct in three two we won't
dare play it but Ain't No Sunshine by
Bill Withers is playing over this scene
and if you know you know that you know
you know the sin is I know
foreign
you know what I was thinking about on my
run over here
chocolate lava cake hey
come on Brothers don't shake hands
Brothers gotta hug a family
I'll always be watching over you always
watching where'd you go I I had to poop
as for the sergeant big pen
and fling it
26 yards
right into the asshole's eyeball
dead shot dead shirt what's your point
my point is that the pen is bite you
after the sword did you have
sex with him probably not in the way
you're thinking
that baby is an accessory to murder you
got the right to remain silent [__] you
can honor me the way a wife is required
to honor a husband you played my butt
like jazz you like jazz I see you I see
you